hello
and thank you for joining us for this
webinar sponsored by asia biosciences
which is now part of agilent technology
my name is yama abbasi and i'm the vice
president of business development
and i'll be your host for today's
webinar
before i introduce our speaker for today
allow me to share a bit about
agilent technologies and the products we
offer for cell analysis
agilent is a trusted leader in life
sciences
clinical research diagnostics and
applied chemical markets
providing laboratories with instruments
services consumables applications
and expertise to enable our customers to
gain
the insights they seek asea
is one of the newest additions to
agilent cell analysis divisions
which includes seahorse luxel
and also biotech which was recently
acquired agilent's rapidly growing cell
analysis portfolio enables deeper
more reliable insight across a variety
of cell analysis applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
complex cellular environments and
interactions
including salt faith fitness and
function
our comprehensive cell analysis tools
are critically important
in various investigation fields such as
cancer
inflammation immuno immunology
infectious diseases and you'll find that
today
immune oncology
even though the origins of the
immunotherapy field can be traced back
to the beginnings of the 19th century
modern immunotherapy as we understand it
had its origins
about a decade ago with the introduction
of various antibodies such as
those that blocked immune checkpoints
including ctla-4
pd1 and pdl-1 as well as engineered
antibodies such as bites and
by specifics and oncolytic viruses
adoptive cell therapies such as tills
and engineered t
cells have propelled the field of cancer
therapy to a whole other level
the ability to harness and co-opt the
exquisite
specificity memory and adaptability of
the immune system
to achieve better efficacy is something
that the field is truly
striving to achieve we do see
and envision that there is
an important role for non-perturbing
real-time functional assays that are
predictive
and uh play an important role in
improving the efficacy of these new
treatments and also for
understanding the underlying toxicities
the excellence instruments offered
by cf biosciences is composed of a
number of
instruments which primarily differ in
the throughput that they offer
the standard excelligence instrument
utilizes special microtiter plates
with impedance with embedded impedance
biosensors
our latest addition is the esight
system where we have combined impedance
biosensor technology together with live
cell
imaging capability which will be covered
in today's
webinar
it now gives me great pleasure
to introduce today's speaker dr michael
overstreet doctor overstreet obtained
his bachelor's of science in biomedical
engineering
and his phd in molecular microbiology
and immunology
from johns hopkins university
he performed his post-doctoral training
at the university of
rochester medical center at the center
for vaccine biology
and immunology subsequent to his
post-doctoral training dr olga stream
had held group leader positions at
multiple
biopharma companies he is currently
associate principal scientist in
oncology
discovery at astrazeneca
before i hand over the mic
to mike i would like to remind you that
this webinar
is interactive and they will be question
and answer period immediately following
the talk
you will notice on your screen that you
can
and in fact you should please type in
your questions during the presentation
in the q a field as this helps ensure
that we get as many questions as
possible
also there's a link to some resources on
the screen
please feel free to click on those
during or after the presentation
with that thank you
and dr overstreet please take it away
okay thank you yama for the intro and
thanks for the opportunity to
share some of the work that we've been
doing to develop some models of
anti-tumor t-cell responses that are hla
and peptide restricted
but ultimately the goal of having a
robust and
reliable platform for testing candidate
therapeutics
alone and and in combination
so i'll start off here today with a
little bit of a rationale and
description of the approach that we've
taken
and why we think it's worth the effort
and then i'll cover some example data
that highlights
a few of our key learnings around the
parameters that are really important to
consider in these in these kinds of
assays
and then finally we'll show some of the
learnings uh from our recent evaluation
using a multiplex readout
of the of the e site that that yama just
alluded to
so if we start out with our rationale
what we want to try and understand is
how we can best
uh try and model the cognate
interactions
between a t cell and a tumor cell and by
cognate i mean those
governed by the t cell receptor and the
peptide hla
complex and this is really critical
because antitumor t cells are really the
keystone
for the vast majority of
immunotherapeutic approaches
being used and tested right now for the
treatment of cancer
car t cells are certainly
revolutionizing treatment paradigms and
some of the hematological
malignancies but in solid tumors given
the antigenic heterogeneity we believe
that
these endogenous t cell responses to
tumor antigens
are still likely to be fundamental to
the success of even these adoptive cell
therapy
and yet given the a huge worldwide
investment
in cancer immunotherapy our ability to
study these interactions between a human
t
cell and a human tumor cell actually
quite limited
but what exactly do we mean by this
so while all cells in the body
they must respond to a pretty complex
array of signals coming from their
extracellular
environment the memory to lymphocytes
are among the most
dynamic of cells constantly traversing
nearly all tissues in the body
scanning the surface of these cells in
search of their cognate antigen
and when they find that the signal that
comes through their t-cell receptor
initiates a cascade
that results in the activation of the
cell what this activation looks like
will
really depend on um
combination of other signals that that
the cell receives so in addition
to the t cell receptor um
they'll also have a network of signals
coming through both positive
co-stimulation
and regulatory receptors or checkpoint
receptors here as well as the cytokine
milieu um uh just to name a few here
what we might call simply uh activation
of a cell is actually
the the net result of a much more rich
and complex network of signals
we must be carefully deciphered inside
the cell
so for this reason uh it's critical to
study
these cells in the proper context if we
hope to extract any
any meaningful
and relevant conclusions from our
studies so
over the past half century or so
researchers
found an array of means by which to make
a t t-cell respond and i list a few of
them here
ranging from compounds such as
4-ball esters calcium ionophores and
and lectins to bacterial enterotoxins
to antibodies to foreign hla
all the way down to a cognate
peptide being presented within the
proper hla context
now all these different means of
stimulation all have their place
in the toolbox but we need to be
cognizant of not over interpreting their
role
because while some can generate robust
responses they tell you more about the
capacity of a t
cell to respond to a stimulus not
necessarily
how it will respond in a physiologically
relevant way
and i'll show you hopefully over the
next uh
over the process of this webinar but
even with the
precise stimulation of the peptide hla
complex
still it's still quite easy to
oversaturate your responsiveness and
throw you
your signaling um out of whack in a way
that you won't have any any kind of a
dynamic window to study
any sort of a therapeutically relevant
stimulation so
studying antigen-specific t-cell
responses using peptide hla
give us the best chance i think for
studying
the relevant effects of checkpoint
blockade and a immune agonist in the
context that we would
that they might actually be seen with
inside
the body in the next vivo setting we can
control
that signal strength to some extent
by varying our antigen concentration uh
or using altered peptide ligands in a
way
however these these studies are not
without their challenges
the first of which being a diversity
within the hla or the human leukocyte
antigen
the most poly polymorphic gene set
within uh within our genome
with in the order of two to four
thousand different alleles at each of
our hla
a b and c genes
so that creates significant practical
problems of
being able to identify individual people
with the given hla
and to i identify peptides within a
given hla
now it's not entirely random
within the north american population and
western european
about 40 percent express hla201 and
we're going to
try and leverage this uh within our
studies
but there are a number of other
challenges of identifying exactly
who these individuals are and what
peptides they respond to
that really can limit the utility
of these assays for across a wide
variety of research purposes
so what do we do so we chose to build
our models around
antiviral t cells which are readily
available from
healthy donors and would allow us to
utilize primary t
cells with a minimal exposure time
to the in vitro culture plastic that
would help limit some of the caveats
associated with a long-term culture
but as i mentioned before we're
utilizing
uh peptides that
have been shown to be presented in hla
8201
so we first screened our donor pools for
expression of hla2
by flow cytometry and then those that
were positive
we screened them for six hla a201
restricted
peptides from three different uh common
viral pathogens being epstein-barr
virus influenza a and cytomegalovirus
these six peptides are are are well
characterized for being presented in
a201
and are reasonably have a reasonably
high prevalence within the human
population
so we started screening our donors for
reactivity
to these peptides this involved
incubation of pvmc
for one week with individual peptides
and then looking
for what looked like
effector cells within the cd8 t cell
compartment
of these pbmc and we can see with these
examples flow cytometry plots here that
if we look at co-expression of
two markers of activation in this
context tim3
and cd25 we see cells cultured with
different peptides show different levels
of effector cells
within their population so compared to
no peptide
this donor seems to respond to these
four different peptides here glc gil
and lv and clg not so much to these
other two
and so using this kind of approach uh we
we we created a catalog of of donors
each
with a unique uh fingerprint of which
peptides that they respond to
and using this we can then uh recall
donors
and use them for use in our
our our cytotoxicity assays in order to
do this we have to expand these
antiviral cd8 t cells
very much in the same way that we screen
the cells just culturing our pbmc with
peptide
this time with the addition of il-2 for
one week
and at the end of the one week we
quantify our
effector cells using flow cytometry
again so if we look at our
cd3 positive cells that are then cd8
positive
we see a very nice population of cells
in this red box here
that co express cd25 and tim3
and if we look at the frequency of this
population within the total pbmc
in that whole well or flask rather
that composes about 24 of all the cells
so we get a robust proliferation um
and a relative enrichment of these
antiviral t cells that
uh co-express other markers of of
therapeutic interests as we see in these
histograms
below they express in reds
cd-137 pd1 hladr
tidget icos they look like
bonafide effector cells and they bind
tetramers that
that are specific to the peptide that
they were expanded against
and if we look for three different
specificities here
each of this dot each of these dots
represent a single
a single donor who's been who was shown
to be reactive and then
had t-cells cultured with those
individual peptides
and tetramer reactive cells
showed those relative frequencies within
the the total pbmc
and so we can get upwards of up to uh
50 percent of every cell in that flask
is an antigen-specific t cell and so
this can is a means of generating a
a good and rich pot of antiviral t cells
so the second key element of our
cytotoxicity assay
is the target cell so most
cytotoxicity assays utilize peptide
pulsed target cells
or cells that naturally express the the
target antigen
the peptide pulsing of target cells
however can result in uncontrolled
waning presentation of peptide
uh as the peptide starts falling off the
hla
and then during an extended toe culture
that the
there that we are most interested in um
you really get uncontrolled antigen
presentation
so we wanted stable presentation of our
target antigen
so our our approach was simply to over
express a concatemer of the six
viral peptides that we screened our
donors against
stitched together by linkers and encoded
inside a lentivirus that also had a gfp
tag and so if we take a hla201 positive
tumor cell
and transduce it with a lentivirus
that then forces this cell to express
this polypeptide this polypeptide is
then cut up in in the proteasome
these peptides are loaded on hla201 and
presented on the surface of the cell
for presentation to t cells and all six
of these peptides get presented
and can then be so this target cell can
then be used as something of a universal
target cell for
t cells expanded against any of the six
peptide specificities that we screen for
so the third key element of a
cytotoxicity is a platform
against which we are going to utilize to
measure the tumor cell killing
we know that t cells have many
potentially redundant
mechanisms by which to kill a target
cell
and and often surrogates of cytotoxicity
are used
but given that we don't know what kind
of a mechanism is critical in any given
context
we really want a direct measurement of
cytotoxicity
because we can show a given therapeutic
invention
or therapeutic intervention may increase
a surrogate readout say
production of interferon gamma
but if we don't know that interferon
gamma was important
for killing in that assay or
it was producing enough interference
already and it wasn't
it wasn't a limiting variable by
increasing the amount of
of the cytokine we're not actually going
to affect killing of the tumor cells
so there are a variety of different ways
to measure a direct readout of tumor
cell cytotoxicity
and i've listed a few examples here um
the first two tend to be
uh a bit labor intensive uh and most
importantly they have fixed
endpoints we are most imp
uh interested in a uh something that
not have a fixed standpoint and
something that can measure in real time
and we opted for uh
impedance based measurement primarily
because it's a
label-free platform and it provides uh
an
objective readout in the impedance
that comes out of the system it also
gives you
semi-continuous and real-time data
non-destructive
and also importantly it is pretty
hands-off
so i'll just give you a a quick overview
of the technology for
uh in case you're unfamiliar with it the
accelerance
is an instrument that it measures
electrical resistance across electrodes
at the bottom of a tissue culture well
these plates special plates are coated
in gold-plated electrodes
and the instrument will periodically
send an electrical pulse
across those electrodes and measure the
resistance
in that circuit and we'll read this out
as a measurement of
impedance now if you have
adherent tumor cells growing on top of
your electrodes
it's more difficult for these ions to
complete that circuit and it results in
an increase in electrical resistance
in that well and this is read out on the
instrument as an increase
in impedance and so in the context of a
cytotoxicity assay this is
is leveraged by plating tumor cells that
cover your
electrodes here in step one and create
something of a confluent
monolayer that as these cells adhere
and spread and begin proliferating
um you get an increase in your impedance
signal here
and once you have something of a plateau
you can add your non-adherent
effector cells which will then begin
killing tumor cells as the tumor cells
begin to die
they're no longer adherent and the elect
in your impedance signal will drop
the one of the very nice things about
the system
and the setup in general is that
effector cells t
cell then k cells typically are not
adherent so they contribute
very little to no signal in the assay
this gives actually a very clean
clean signal
and we've used this kind of setup for a
variety of different cytotoxicity assays
i'll show you a couple examples here we
use it for adcc or antibody dependent
cellular cytotoxicity
with nk cells we show it with car
media killing with t-cell clones
uh allergenic t-cell responses as well
as antigen-specific
t-cell responses using anti-viral t
cells
i'm talking about today just one quick
technical note
um the impedance that comes off the
system is reported as a cell index
um and in this example here we have
killing here
in this red line uh there are algorithms
within the software that can convert
these values
into percent cytolysis values so it's
something that will increase
over time and that's how i'll be
reporting my
results in the rest of the webinar as an
increase
in cytolysis over time but all the
underlying data is based on a change in
cell index that drops over time as tumor
cells
are being killed so
um our cytotoxicity assay as i i built
all the pieces
um for you thus far will be a one-week
expansion of our
pre-screen donor pbmc with a single
viral peptide and some il-2
and after the one week the effector
cells within this mixed population are
then quantified
by flow cytometry and then added onto
our
tumor cells that express or don't
express viral peptides
that are have been pre-plated in in
excellence plate so if we jump right in
um we see that when we use target cells
in in the left-hand column here
transduce with viral peptides we get a
nice
titratable killing of the tumor cells
from four different t
cell specificities uh each of these
from four different human donors and
within the
the uh the plot here you see two lines
just
of the same color representing the
duplicate wells
the different line colors being the
different e to t
or factor to target ratios so with the
fixed number of tumor cells in the well
increasing e to t ratio means increasing
numbers of t
cells added to those wells so we you can
see
in this first line we get a nice
titration of
killing that increases over time at our
highest
e to t's here at four and two and then
it titrates down and compare these
responses
to parental tumor cells that do not
express
the viral peptides we don't get any
killing here
so one of the first things i wanted to
point out is our time scale here
these i'm showing data here for 100
hours
this is actually a hundred not a
thousand that's an extra zero
from this over here um but we typically
add our t cells about 24 hours after we
plate our tumor cells and we get about
three days worth of killing curves
so you notice that the first 24 to
40 hours are pretty dynamic in these
assays
and contrast this to
some more traditional cytotoxicity
assays which
which only lasts four to six hours or
possibly overnight
often due to technical reasons
but these longer time points allow us to
use a much lower e to t
ratio and that longer time period
will allow for crosstalk between t cells
and tumor cells in a way that
might approximate something of the in
vivo
environment and the second thing to
point out is
the low e to t ratios that we're using
here i'm only showing a few examples
but we consistently show a saturating
response around
e to t of two or four
and then we we lose responsiveness
around
0.2 or so
this is not actually a huge range
which depending on your perspective
could be good or bad
good that we can pretty easily cover the
whole range of responses within a
given assay but if you're not familiar
with
the these ratios it could be pretty easy
to miss
so the reason we built this platform
is is for testing candidate therapeutics
um so to start out with uh
our first test we we test an anti-pdl-1
antibody and i'll show you data here
from
a single donor um so while we can get
robust anti-tumor responses
uh comparing the black line and the
pink line here with wells treated with
anti-pdl-1
we actually don't see any difference
perhaps maybe at this very low at the
low e to t
you might see a little bit of an
increase but this is not
exactly what we were hoping for so this
is certainly disappointing
at first because our whole goal was
to have a wide a dynamic range here but
even at sub-optimal e to t's we don't
see much
increase here so
that just told us that we weren't quite
done yet so let's bring this to our next
section so our
how we uh optimize and uh and further
and develop these assays
so if we go back to some basic
immunology principles about
how a t cell recognizes its peptide and
hla there are a couple other variables
that will directly impact the stimulus
strength
for a given t cell independent of the
effector
to target ratio which is is more of a
population variable
the first of these being the the peptide
antigen density
on the surface of the cell so this is
typically modulated in assays by
by titrating peptide but we limited
ourselves somewhat in that context
because we wanted a target cell that
stably expressed
the peptides what we did is we
we tried to modulate this antigen
density by changing the promoter
driving the expression of the lentiviral
insert
because we had a gfp tag on our
our viral peptide transient we could
estimate
the the peptide density by looking at
gfp expression
and when we compare gfp expression on
our
our first generation uh target cells
here in red show high gfp and if we
switch and use a weaker promoter
we get this blue histogram here so we
got about a 10-fold
reduction in gfp mfi which we thought
was promising
so we next tested it in our cytotoxicity
assay to see with this lower antigen
density
uh if if we started getting more
sub-optimal
killing and if we look if we compare
curves now that have
high antigen or low antigen being
expressed by our tumor cells or high gfp
and low gfp across four e to t ratios
here we can now see that
clearly the the the lower presentation
of antigen
uh led to a a more difficult time
for the t cells to kill these cells and
we got a a dramatically lower uh
amount of killing particularly at these
uh more
sub-optimal e to t ratios here of around
one
so this was this was encouraging um
but the next actual test was does this
matter for checkpoint blockade and so if
we
revisit the the same donor
data that i showed you before where with
a high level of antigen
we get pretty robust killing and no
window for an anti-pdl-1 treatment
if we then look at the effects of low
antigen uh combined with antipedia one
now we start to see
some separation of these curves where
you know these intermediate e to t
ratios we have a much slower killing
uh though it does uh in the absence of
checkpoint blockade though it does
eventually reach nearly 100 percent
uh this killing is a lot more rapid with
the anti-pdl1 treatment
cases where our killing plateaus
with lower eats we can achieve higher
plateaus with pdl one blockade
but at the lowest to t's it still does
require a critical
number of t cells to clear those tumor
cells out of the well but now we're
beginning to see some daylight in
between these curves
and uh so we're we thought we were on
the right track here so if we look at
a third variable that we can tune in
these assays is the affinity of the tcr
for its peptide hla complex
so it's been shown the antiviral t cells
tend to have
t cell receptors that are of a higher
affinity
for their peptide hla than tcrs that are
specific for tumor neo-epitopes
so to try and make this model a bit more
relevant to endogenous anti-tumor t
cells we tested whether we could modify
the viral peptide epitope being
presented by the tumor cell
in a way that would attenuate but not
entirely ablate recognition by the
antiviral t
cell now this can be a tricky endeavor
as t cells tend to be exquisitely
sensitive
to even small changes in their peptide
but sometimes changes can be tolerated
and i'll spare you all
the background of the screening that we
did to identify a peptide and an
altered peptide ligand but in this small
curve here using soluble peptide
of the wild type epitope here in orange
we see with this altered peptide ligand
that just has a single point mutation
in the peptide we we have a blunted
cytotoxicity profile here so what we
next did
is we generated two new cell lines that
express the mutant
peptide at either a high antigen density
or a low antigen density
using the same two lentiviral promoters
that we've used
already so if we start off
um here i'm just showing two effector to
target ratios
this time back vertically and again if
we have
high antigen density with the native
wild type
peptide sequence we don't see any
effects
of our anti-pdl1 treatment
if we then have low antigen
density and low energy presentation
and a sub-optimal ent e to t we can now
show a pretty clear effect of pdl-1
blockade
in this context now if we switch
to using an altered peptide ligand while
driven at
high expression by the lentiviral
promoter
we still get very weak baseline killing
here but we
but we're able to get to generate a very
potent
response using the anti-pdo1 antibody
but this is
e to t dependent and this is loss at the
next lower e to the t
and if we combine these two variables
and have low antigen expression
of the altered peptide ligand we lose
reactivity
almost entirely and even with checkpoint
blockade here of antipdl1 we get only a
very weak response
at the higher e to t now each donor
will respond to this altered peptide
ligand in a a different way
but with in our hands we tested six
different donors
against this and all but one still
reacted to the altered peptide ligand
and whether they responded more strongly
to the
altered peptide ligand at high density
or the wild type peptide at low density
was donor dependent
excuse me
all right so i'm going to change gears a
little bit here
and turn a little a little bit towards
uh trying to multiplex some of these
readouts
using the e-sight that yama alluded to
before
now the east side is a new instrument um
it combines the impedance of the
accelerants
with some real time three channel
fluorescent and bright field imaging
of the same wells so this really allows
you to maximize your
orthogonal readouts to give a more
complete picture of what's happening
in your assay and using some example
images from the
asea website um that i put in the
presentation here
one of the things that we've been
interested in looking at uh was a
kinetics of interferon gamma production
in the course
of our killing assays we would often
harvest
supernatants at the end and look for
endpoint
interferon gamut production but we
thought this could provide an
interesting platform
to look at interferon gamma
being produced in in real time so
what we chose to do was
to use a stat one responsive element
that could drive expression of a
fluorescent protein
so in this context in this case we used
m cherry
so that when the t cell engages its
antigen
produces interferon gamma this cell
is is going to die but this cell that
hasn't yet been
killed but has seen interferon gamma
will
if it has a stat1 responsive element
produce m cherry
and turn red we would be able to
visualize
uh interferon gamma production uh
in in real time if we look at how how
the cells respond i'll show you a movie
here we can watch
as the tumor cells begin at hearing
over the first 24 hours of the imaging
and when we add interferon gamma we can
start to see m
cherry being expressed over time
now we see some heterogeneity within the
cells
let me see if i'll play that again
um and i think this has to do that these
these cells that we're working with here
are just a
a mixed pool i think if we did some
some cloning we get a really nice
homogeneous response but this is
a pretty clear signal for us to begin
working with
so if you look at the kinetics of this m
cherry being produced
in quantitation over time we see a nice
dose response
that begins several hours after the
addition of the cytokine
and continues to increase for about 40
to 50 hours
and and then it plateaus
and when looking at a titration of
interferon gamma
we see a nice titration of the the
signal but not a terribly wide dynamic
range if you look at our
our bottom concentration of interferon
gammas
uh around 60 picogram per mil which
still gives us a very
clear signal above our uh our background
here
but it may not be terribly quantitative
for uh
extrapolating concentrations out of a a
given well
uh and and by means of like a standard
curve or something
but what we wanted to do next was try
and multiplex this
in our killing assays and we also wanted
to add in
a third readout for
dead and dying tumor cells and this
would allow us
for to have a reading of tumor cell
death
independent of the impedance so we can
compare the
these readouts as well and for this we
chose a
fluorescent substrate for cleave
caspase-3
and when a tumor cell or any cell
rather killed
in this context the t cell will produce
interferon gamma
turn adjacent cells red this cell
will die activate caspase-3 in the
process and become bright green
so one caveat using a
substrate like this is that it's not
going to be specific for our tumor cells
but it will give us a good indication
of the
quantity of cells that are dying in the
well
now some t cells will die over the
course of this assay but
from a practical standpoint t cells are
actually a lot smaller
than our tumor cells and is pretty
straightforward within the analysis
algorithm to exclude small green
uh and dead cells from the much larger
green tumor cells
so if we look at what happens um
when we start putting all these pieces
together let's see if this movie will
start going
again we we have our our tumor cells at
hearing over the first 24 hours and our
t
cells and descend upon them and start
killing tumor cells and we see
this uh at first gradual and then pretty
uh rapid increase in in dead tumor cells
green caspase-3 positive uh
dead and dying tumor cells as well as
the red m cherry
signal coming up let me play this again
so we have a nice accumulation of
of dying tumor cells pretty a pretty
complete clearing in this
example of tumor cells from the well
if we look at the multiplex readouts
across
effector to target ratios and here i'm
showing
data from three different donors run on
on the same plate and these are using
the
the tumor cells that were expressing the
low density of
antigen and so we can see that we have
this is looking at the percent cytolysis
using the impedance measurements
we have a very robust anti-tumor
response from donor one you can pretty
effectively clear almost all the tumor
cells
even at a modest e to t of one
whereas donor two is perhaps more
typical
uh we get these more intermediate
response and donor three
uh is actually a bit weaker than we
typically observe
but but this gives us a nice spectrum of
activity uh
in this assay we would say that
that donor three wasn't controlling the
tumor cell growth very well
but if we look at the number of cleave
caspase-3 positive cells
we can see starting on the left uh our
kinetics
they match quite nicely our impedance
readout
on the left but as we we go across over
to donor two and then over to donor
three
the y-axis scales on these plots are all
the same
donor three is actually generating quite
a few dead tumor cells
these are it doesn't quite reach the
the plateau level that we see in donor
one and perhaps the
rate of killing maybe the slope of this
curve isn't quite as steep
but this donor doesn't look to be quite
as inert uh as one might
interpret from the impedance based graph
so there is a bit of a disconnect here
if we look at the
the m cherry signal um this time
looking across all three donors we
actually see pretty comparable kinetics
i didn't know quite what to make of this
but if we start looking at a snapshot
to do a bit more of a gut check on
does our data match what we actually see
with our eyes
if we look at a snapshot in these wells
from the last time point for donor one
really all we see left are small
lymphocytes
and green cell and debris
so our dead tumor cells in donor two it
had a mean
intermediate response uh we see quite a
bit
of red left behind and i don't know i'm
not sure how well the um
the bright field imaging is going to
transmit
but there are regions where we don't see
any tumor cells
on on the right and on the left part of
this image
but the bottom and center still have
substantial
uh confluent tumor cells and in donor
three
still have pretty intense red and cherry
signal here indicating that we do have
production of interferon gamma in this
well
we do have dead tumor cells
but there's pretty much a confluent
monolayer of tumor cells in this well
while
t cells from donor three
were able to uh kill some tumor cells
produce interferon gamma it wasn't
ultimately able to
control the net growth of those tumor
cells in that well
perhaps but the pace of their killing
was too slow and as the tumor cells were
just
able to regrow and repopulate that well
and these are the things that we're
still working on
on trying to figure out and so what's
the difference between these three
donors
unfortunately i don't have an answer for
you today this is actually my
last uh in data slide but if we step
back we have three parallel sets of data
that could lead to very different
interpretations of what's actually
happening
in the well now i'm also only showing
the baseline killing data we haven't
treated
these wells with any antibodies or or
stimulants
when we start layering on therapeutic
interventions and combinations we start
generating very rich and dense data sets
for which we can begin extracting
meaning and learn what could be the more
important parameters to modify
in our t cell's behavior and function
that would ultimately lead us to the end
that we seek which is the clearance of
the tumor cells
out of these wells so having multiple
orthogonal readouts can provide a much
more complete picture of what's going on
and provide a much better platform for
much
to make some important decisions based
on the data
so to wrap up
we've shown that uh antiviral t cells
can be used to model anti-tumor t cell
responses
and then by carefully balancing several
variables that can impact the function
of an individual t
cell as well as a net response of a
population of these t
cells we can engineer a stable platform
for testing of immunomodulatory
antibodies and and proteins
and by dialing back our stimulation
conditions along these several axes we
can controllably reduce
our baseline killing and create
substantial windows to show
combinatorial activity
using multiple therapeutic agents and
modalities
by multiplexing our readouts with
impedance and imaging we've already
begun
making insights into our anti-tumor
responses that would be have been very
difficult if if possible at all to make
using a single readout system
and finally i'd like to thank just a
handful of the many folks that have
contributed this work
especially james laurie and christina
who helped with the engineering and
production of our cell lines
roy and vanessa agneska for generating
much of the data for these studies only
a snapshot of which i was able to show
here today
and finally the guys over at ac
especially knight chen lincoln and fabio
for their
support over the last few years and if
i've left any time i'll be happy to take
any questions that have come through
okay thank you very much mike for that
uh
really excellent uh presentation
uh we will now start the question and
answer portion of that webinar
if you have a question that you'd like
to ask please submit it now and
we'll be able to get a to a couple of
questions at the end of the hour however
if we
don't make it to your questions we'll be
forwarding all of them on to mike and we
will make sure that we
follow up with you additionally if you
would like to learn more once again
about
our solutions uh that we offer please do
visit our website and
also click on that resource box that
i've mentioned before
so uh so mike we got a number of really
good questions and uh let's uh get
started
the first question is how do you
balance the density and quality of
peptide
to get optimal cytotoxicity
um that's a good question um
and something that uh
kind of has to be done somewhat
empirically
we didn't know quite how we were going
to
how changing the lentiviral promoter
would affect what ultimately ends up on
the surface of the
of the tumor cell i had actually feared
um that um even by lowering it
as much as we did it would still be too
much because there are
reports in the literature that t cells
are able to detect as as
few as one or two peptide hla complexes
on a tumor cell
but uh we've we have some efforts trying
to quantify the
the number of peptides that are actually
being presented on
the cells but i i'm not able to share
that data here today
and so the the the short answer is we we
try and do both
um i i think
based on our data that the most uh
linear and dynamic conditions are
poor antigen quality at high density
uh or or native uh antigen quality at
low density
those seems to kind of be the two
two conditions where the majority of the
donors that we've tested
show the most dynamic responses
great and in relating to to that
question mike
someone also asked whether the your
tumor cell
line has an equal sort of propensity to
express
all of these different peptides so you
get different levels of
expression of presentation
uh yeah that's a good question um and
and also one that's a little bit
difficult to answer
as i mentioned we're trying to do uh
some quantitation
by mass spec to see if we can actually
quantitate the number of each peptide
uh because the only other way we really
have to
to know that there's peptide there is
that
the teeth that they're able to be killed
by a t
cell that recognizes that that single
peptide
and given the range of
affinities of different t cell receptors
and different clonalities that we're
working with
there's not a good answer to the
question
unfortunately we it's also one that we
we've approached somewhat empirically
and just by trying to
change promoters change the uh
the structure of the actual lentiviral
construct
different linkers seem to have an impact
on the amount of peptide that reaches
the surface and so that's that's also
something that we've
just arrived at somewhat empirically
okay great thank you um there's another
question here
which asks if you checked for t
cell exhaustion after co-culture with
high and low
antigen target cells
uh yeah that's that's a very good
question
and there are some folks within our
research group
that are trying to study just that
whether repetitive co-culture with
tumor cells with high or low antigen
will result in t cell exhaustion
unfortunately that's not something i'm
able to comment on right now it is
certainly a a
a a good question and one that we are
actively uh
engaged in great thank you
there's a another question here uh which
asks
do you enrich the antigen specific
cd25 positive 10 3 positive
cells before using them in the impedance
assay
um i have we have done it enrichments
and depending on the relative frequency
of those effector cells within
the population it can really help you
but given the numbers of cells that we
tend to work with
i usually don't i found that if the
effector cells
are at least 10 of the total pbmc
than the number of non-effector pbmc
that i'm adding into the well
and have very little impact on the tumor
cells
in terms of inducing a non-specific
or antigen independent killing of those
tumor cells
now for better or worse this will be
different for every tumor cell line
there are some tumor cells that are are
very hardy
and uh and and can happily accommodate
you know half a million
uh pbmc in the well with them uh there
are
other tumor cell lines that uh are a bit
more fragile
um and may not accept even a hundred
thousand
total uh pbmc so
um unfortunately that one is also
something um
that's a bit empiric uh in the times
where i do
enrich the t cells
i i i've shied away from
directly enriching the uh
cd25 tim three positive i typically will
just do a negative
uh selection for the total cd8s
and that tends to work quite well
because in that context i will get
typically get about 40 to 50 percent of
the
the cells after that will be of the
effector phenotype
great thank you mike um so the
the specific target cell that you had
used was
an adherent cell line what if
the target cell is
basically a suspension cell how would
one deal with that in this impedance
essay
yeah so um i don't have a lot of
first-hand experience with that but i
it's something we're starting to explore
i believe ac offers some
tethering antibodies basically just
that you coat the bottom of the well
with
and the tumor cells are then stuck to
the bottom of the well
and functionally then provide an
impedance signal
and you can operate the assay in very
much the same way
without that kind of approach yet the
impedance really
won't work you would need to go to
something more
either a traditional flow cytometry
based assay or
perhaps just an imaging alone assay
and along those lines someone also asked
what is the benefit of the excellence
real-time assay compared to
the flow cytometry assay
can you can you just comment on the some
of the advantages or the differences
between the two approaches
yeah um well compared to flow cytometry
i i think it's
it is um it's not even close
um the flow cytometry is a
a fixed endpoint and so you get one
slice
one picture in time it is
quite labor intensive in terms of
processing you need to harvest your
cells out of the well
stain them run them on the flow
cytometer analyze all the data
which can be somewhat subjective and in
order to get
good data you need to either have
labeled t cells or labeled tumor cells
to distinguish them
on the flow cytometer um if you're
having an adherent tumor cell
uh it's best practice in my hands
actually
even to trypsinize them out of the well
so you're not overestimating your
killing rate
so there's it's pretty labor intensive
uh with the
impedance based assay uh you plate your
tumor cells
the day before you add your t cells
uh and that's it you set it you watch it
and you come back and check periodically
but ultimately
your data is delivered at the end in a
data file that you can then
analyze once the experiment is over
and and the data is not subjective it's
an objective readout
so i i like that aspect of it as well
it's not
subject to where you draw a gate
to determine where your your viable and
dead tumor cells are
so for a variety of reasons uh i
certainly
favor the impedance
not the least of which is the the ease
of use
great uh so we still have a number of
really great questions
unfortunately we won't get to all of
them but we'll ask
just one last question since we have to
reach the top of the hour
so you've you've shown mike that
in with the eastside system really three
different ways of
measuring potency of the t cells using
impedance
of the basically interfering
gamma-mediated fat activation and also
measurement of cash basis
can you comment on the differences and
potencies
between the different types of
readouts
um i guess what do you mean by
potency if i might
uh i guess uh
in terms of the killing rate uh let's
say i guess that's
that's probably what is meant in this in
this particular case if you're seeing
any
differences in terms of the killing rate
uh between the different readouts
yeah i think you know with the the
caspase-3
readout um you're visualizing a tumor
cell
as it dies and it stays there um
you know within the field of view
for as long as it is visible but before
it breaks apart
with the impedance
i feel like it gives you more of a a a
net result uh kind of where where the
battle line
is in the on a population basis
um so while um
the the imaging can give you a a
sensitive readout for killing of
individual tumor cells
so it may actually give you a perhaps a
more sensitive readout
depending on your background levels um
it may overestimate how well your t
cells are doing
uh i think as evidenced by the
comparison
with the impedance data because the the
the difference between the caspase
readout and the uh between the
the high performing donor and and the
poor performing donor was actually not
all that different
but the impedance based readout was
dramatically different so i think having
the
the multiple readouts allows you to
really triangulate
what's going on and have a more complete
story of
of what's happening
great as i mentioned we still have a
number of other really great questions
unfortunately
we won't be able to get to them during
this live webinar but we will
indeed pass these questions on to mike
and we will
make sure to get you an answer as soon
as possible
so with that thank you again mike for a
really
excellent presentation and also thanks
to our audiences for uh
really being interactive and asking
great uh questions
and uh with that uh thanks again and
have a great day
okay thanks so much
you